good morning John ha ha so last video
there were several comments telling me
how good my hair looked this it was
extremely troubling to me because they
do not want you to like me because of my
hair so I went and got it cut and
unfortunately it looks so good now so I
just can't make it look bad what is that
I see in life what is that oh oh oh sure
and if that does that poster either well
I know what I'm doing
we got posters this is the first time
we've ever had posters and they are for
sale now dftba.com
thank you so much to the nerdfighters
who designed those ryan for this poster
that the llama was done by Lorien and
vom Dale Swain did the Ellen Hardcastle
Hank green one we don't have many of
those actually we also don't have many
of the French the llama posters so be
fast on the stuff something in the
description of my last video now when
you write a lot of words in your life
which I do invariably organic sometimes
come out wrong either because like I
literally don't know what I'm doing or
because I started as since and then I
said in the middle sentence that I
wanted to change how the sentence was
gonna go so the beauty of the sentence
doesn't fit with the second part of the
sentence it just happens that stuff
happened I like that we strive for it
but no one is always going to be perfect
there is one profession in America above
all other professions that needs to know
the rules of grammar no it is not the
editor of the New York Times no it is
not novelists or even copy editors for
novels all those people are not to make
mistakes the one profession that cannot
will not should not ever yes tattoo
artists oh god no I'm gonna get
something improvement Lia fix to your
skin you better copy it at first
otherwise you're gonna have to go back
in and get one of those like Microsoft
Word wavy grammar incorrect lines there
fix that for you end of that rant
starting new one there was much
discussion my last video about how I
said that the majority of sensing organs
that we have are on our heads I left out
a whole lot of senses like the sense of
hunger in the sense of equilibrium in
the sense of knowing where your body
parts are in the sense of fullness of
the cold any people who follow me on
tumblr you've heard this before but just
bear with me because the rest of the
math there is something special about
the five senses that we learn in school
the eyes the nose the mouth the ears and
the skin these are the five sensing
organs that allow us to experience the
world whereas the rest of those senses
allow us to experience our selves and
that is why we are taught that when
we're in grade school not because it's a
lot
but because it's a simplification of the
tree so that's two problems that you had
with my last video that I am not
accepting were actually my fault part by
the way you can only order posters you
can't do without the dftba items this is
because it has to ship in a tube and our
other items don't fit inside of tubes
it's complicated but to make up for that
fact the shipping on the posters is free
so that's good I just watched the
trailer from Ruby shark Night 3d uh I
have some advice for the protagonists of
that movie okay so you add a lake house
uh and your friend is skiing and he gets
eaten by a shark movie ends there
maybe it'll be interesting movie all the
fruits after more in his death but but
there's not gonna be anyone else who
dies because you now know that there's a
shark in the light don't go back in the
water
done you're safe finally for you I have
three quick updates one John is going to
make a Great Gatsby video on Monday -
I'm working hard on my Ellen Hardcastle
ten word videos and three we've received
a lot like six thousand entries to the
nerd Factor contest and so it's taking
us a little while to get through all
those I'm sorry but we are doing it and
a lot of them are really amazed John
I'll see you on what day Monday one day
yeah